immigration lawyers say the Pentagon has
been discharging dozens of recruits who
had been promised a path to US
citizenship they were part of a program
called military accessions vital to the
national interest it had brought more
than ten thousand non-citizens into the
military the program was abruptly
suspended in 2016 leaving more than a
thousand recruits in limbo David Pegg
know is at an army training camp in San
Antonio he spoke with a soldier who
fears her American Dream is slipping
away David good morning good morning
John you're about to meet a woman who
came to the US legally to go to college
and then signed up for the US military
because she says she wanted to earn her
US citizenship in an honourable way
she's been serving the military on
active duty for the last two years
waiting for a background check to be
completed and she just found out that
she failed it and now she expects the
military to kick her out but she still
showed up for work here at Camp Bullis
in San Antonio at 6:00 a.m. this morning
the dedication and service that they do
I thought they just it was extraordinary
because it's a volunteer force so I
wanted to be part of that private first
class alina collusion doesn't know when
she'll get her official discharge orders
for more than two years this Ukrainian
immigrant has been unable to clear new
background checks her dreams of becoming
a nurse and commissioned u.s. army
officer are dimming by the day I got
screwed a little bit screwed collusion I
enlisted under a military recruit
program called MAVNI militaria sessions
vital to the national interest
it offers non-citizens a path to
citizenship if they have critical
language and medical skills needed by
the military the Bush administration
started the program to help fight the
war on terror
President Obama opened it up to daca
recipients the so-called dreamers and
that brought tougher screenings for
recruits in 2016 they ordered so many
background checks that they destroyed
the program immigration attorney
Margaret stock a former Army lieutenant
colonel who helped create maddening says
not enough resources were provided for
the additional investigations resulting
in a ten-year backlog the background
vetting that
defense is ordered on these people is
much much stricter than any vetting that
is done for a US citizen getting a job
at the White House we should limit the
number of people we accept Andy Harris
is a Maryland congressman and former
navy medical officer he supports ending
maddening saying the military should be
looking to recruit Americans first I'm
not opposed to the idea of looking for
critical needs for the military but
again I fully agree with the enhanced
background checks because these are
people who have not been vetted through
the normal immigration and
naturalization process a Pentagon
spokeswoman told CBS News MAVNI was
suspended in 2016 because it was
vulnerable to an unacceptable level of
risk from insider threats such as
espionage terrorism and other criminal
activity collusion his records indicate
she was flagged because of discrepancies
in her answers during her security
review her screener believed her ability
to protect classified information has
been compromised you were committed your
life to a bigger purpose and anybody
who's willing to do that there's a
respect and be treated as a human not as
a piece of paper
latest says her screeners believe that
someone else in the Ukraine was
supporting her financially and that made
her a security risk nor if she believes
that she gets deported from the US the
Ukraine will now see her as a traitor
well incredibly complicated David thank
you so much I mean this raises a lot of
questions for soldiers who are serving
who may not yet be citizens that's right
feel her pain though there are absolute
she wanted that job